An agent opens a pull request. It passes
the tests. It updates the documentation.
It closes the issue and comments, "Looks
done to me."
But is it actually done?
Is it done enough to merge? Is it done
enough to deploy? Is it done enough to
announce to your customers? These are
fundamentally different operational
claims, and most agent systems just
flatten it to a single green check mark.
I'm Dota. I'm the creator of Paperclip,
and I'm going to give you some
hard-earned lessons that we've learned
in creating Paperclip's liveness model.
What does done even mean? Here's the
thing. Programming is solved, and agents
can now produce more code and
documentation faster than any human can
ever verify.
And this actually gives us a new failure
mode, is that agents can actually create
more work than humans have time to
verify. So we need a way to verify that
our agents are done more than just
letting them check a checkbox.
Done doesn't mean that an agent just
changed the status of a task being done.
Saying that something is done is
actually a bundle of claims. You're
saying that an artifact was produced,
that you have evidence that the task is
actually complete, and you have a rubric
in which you can verify against. You
know exactly who the owner is for the
next step, and you know exactly what the
next step is.
There's different levels to how done
something is. The producer might claim
something is complete, but you need to
have a reviewer, another party that
looks at it and finds no obvious issues.
You want to verify and make sure that
the evidence actually meets a specified
standard. You want to make sure that a
person who is authorized to approve it
actually approves that the work is done.
And you want to make sure that there's
somebody who actually stands behind the
decision. And ideally, what you want is
that the outcome has actually survived
real-world conditions.
Because exhaustive human verification
fails at high volume. You might be able
to verify a few tasks per day, but
essentially, if you have humans
verifying all the tasks and they have to
sign off on it, you eventually what you
just get is a form of verification
theater. What you need is a protocol for
defining how tasks actually progress
through a system. You want to make sure
that tasks are always kept moving, but
they don't get stuck into invalid
states. You need a control plane that
actually has the execution of the tasks
being tied to specific contracts and
constraints about what the system will
do
and what agents it will hand off your
next task to.
Because really what you're trying to
play against is this idea around keeping
work moving, but also having it
verified. When a task has been reviewed
by a human, you get the assurance that
it's correct. But having a human verify
it means that the task is dead in its
tracks. You also want to keep
liveliness. Liveliness means that the
work is continuing with no blockers.
And you're always trying to keep these
two things in balance. If you have tasks
that are completely alive with no
approvals, then what you get is this
classic AI slop because you're producing
a lot of things with kind of no quality
control and it's worse than creating
nothing after a long period of time. But
if you have peer review, um then you
have this enormous review queue where
humans can't actually review it by hand
anyway. These agents will be creating
far more than you can ever actually
review, and so we have to find a way to
tease apart the bundle of claims that
are involved in saying a task is done.
With Paperclip, we have a number of
mechanisms to keep this going. You might
think that you can easily just write a
for loop over your task manager and have
your agents work, but quickly you'll
find that falls apart. As soon as you
start integrating task dependency trees,
blockers, multiple agents, item potent
checkouts, like locks on checkouts,
you find that this tension between
liveliness and verification actually
gets quite complicated.
There's really three invariants that are
extremely important when you're thinking
about what you want out of a control
plane for your agentic work. You want to
ensure that productive work continues.
You want to make sure that only real
blockers stop work. And you want to make
sure that infinite loops are bounded. In
Paperclip, we have built a number of
mechanisms to deal with this problem.
So, for example, every time you have a
task, there's clear transitions to what
the next state could be. We have
first-class blockers between tasks, and
the control plane enforces those
blockers.
We have moments of interactive human
approval, where human choices leave an
audit trail.
You can set reviewers and approvers on
tasks explicitly, meaning when this task
completes, another agent can review it.
We also have the idea of watchdogs,
which is this maximizer mode, which
says,
um, try as hard as you can to make sure
that this happens. When you have a
watchdog, it's another agent, um, who is
given a goal, and it enforces that all
of your agents continue to work until
that goal has been achieved. The
important thing here is that the
watchdog within Paperclip is harness
agnostic. You can use it with Pi,
OpenGL, Hermes, Claude Code, Codex,
whatever you're using, you have one
consistent interface for ensuring that
goal is complete.
So, one of the best pieces of advice we
have is that you stop treating done as a
Boolean and treat it more like an
object.
This isn't specific to Paperclip. It's
just advice on how you think about what
is done. Humans automatically paper over
these details, but when we're building
agentic systems, it's important that
your agents can distinguish between the
different pieces of what they're
claiming when they say something is
done. The artifact that they're saying
is complete, the scope, the rubric or
the standard, the evidence that it's
done, who verified the work, who has the
authority to sign off on the work, And
what risk might be left? And really,
what's the next action going to be? So,
you want to make sure that when you
define done, it's not just a checkbox.
So, if you want to get 100 times more
work done, you should steal this
checklist. You need to define exactly
what does done mean for this task.
You definitely want to separate the
verifier from the author. Often, this
means you're using a different model.
So, if you're coding using Claude, have
Codex verify.
You want to ask your agents to provide
evidence. Don't just ask them to say,
"Is this done?" But, give them the tools
they need to verify that the work is
done. Write the code to have the custom
browser harness.
Write the code to take the screenshots.
Make sure they have access to a browser.
Make sure that they have custom agent
hooks or custom agent tooling to
actually run through and click the
buttons and try it out themselves and
verify that the work is truly done.
Make sure you have a clear chain of
custody, that every agent knows that as
soon as they're done, who they're
supposed to give the work to next.
It can be easy to just fire off a
single-line instruction and vibe with
whatever comes back. But, if you have
serious work that you're accountable
for, it's very important that you define
what done really means in as much detail
as possible, and that you have a
structure for your agents, so that way
they can verify that all of the claims
that are involved with something being
done are actually met. Thank you.